[Music]  our good to see you again so soon mr.  week I need you him to tell this desk  another guy not always that guy John I  can't help you  you're not house if you don't that is  you know the consequences  Accounts Payable how may I help you  I'd like to open an account game on the  account John week the contract has gone  international you have no idea what's  coming  somebody please get this man a gun  with a little corn you stab the devil in  the back to him this isn't venues  this is justice mostly don't think any  me I put a little purple  you working right so whoever comes I'll  kill them  I'll kill them all  I'll try and do the same mmm - and what  style  tactical